good evening it was a tragic weekend on
the historic west side of town as two
homicides took place in the same
neighborhood thanks for joining us I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis both
of those murders happening near MLK and
Lake Mead Madison Kimbrough spoke to a
family member of one of the victims
Madison joins us live from Metro Police
Headquarters with those details
Metro Police confirming that both
homicides are separate incidents and
while the ongoing violence in the area
has caused some major grief within the
West Side Community
we're just here for support I can't
speak on what's going on or how it
occurred I'm just here from my dad that
was Patrice russum the stepdaughter a 54
year old William Hill Jr Hill lost his
life Saturday afternoon when a man came
up to him and his friends while they
were outside and shot him multiple times
he'll later died at UMC Hills Family
hosting a candlelight vigil and balloon
release exclusively telling eight news
now what type of man he was to the
community he didn't have an enemy
nowhere everybody represented him
everybody showed him love he was a very
good cook that's what I that's what I'm
gonna miss Peter gave me none of his
Secrets this unfortunately wasn't the
only shooting to occur on hassle Avenue
police say 43-year-old Clarence Harvey
III was shot and killed the next day at
a nearby Gathering those with giddens
Memorial Chapel held a Stop the Violence
March this month in response to the
senseless violence in town particularly
here on the historic west side and with
these most recent shootings it's obvious
how much work needs to be done it's
really sad to see it continue on and
with the work that we're doing you know
we're we're just we're not giving up
even though we just had the March we're
going to continue the effort of pushing
non-violence within that community
Metro Police still looking for the
suspect who killed William Hill Jr now
Hill is survived by his wife Angela his
four adult children and several
grandkids reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now